oh
I know I know my answer and I think I
know your answer I think this is easy
abortion is worse than slavery
one two three yeah for sure I don't
think abortions worse than slavery how
not because I think there are cases when
abortion is acceptable
well and there's no case where slavery
is correct
okay there's a couple ways to approach
this but let's take it the first one
when do you think abortion would be
acceptable
um early on very early on also if
there's like some severe deformities
where the kid is not going to survive
those are cases when abortion is
acceptable why would you say so I mean
why do you think that that would be
acceptable then let's say because those
are too distinct for sure I'm just
giving two cases where I would say those
things are far more acceptable than
slavery
but it wouldn't you wouldn't say it's
acceptable to kill
you you wouldn't say it's acceptable to
have an abortion in the first trimester
objectively you're just saying it would
be more acceptable than slavery no I I'm
for I am pro-choice early on although
decreasingly so given uh uh it's it's
kind of very um disturbing to me as a
life of a New Yorker to see how many of
these slippery slope arguments across
different issues have not only been
validated but like not only they put
butter and margarine on that slope they
also but I Can't Believe It's Not Butter
so it's just like that thing is so it's
greasiness because it's got seed oils on
it and the seed oil poison yeah um but
because my argument
my argument that that I think would be
acceptable within a kind of libertarian
or anarchistic framework for why
abortion is always worse than slavery is
that
abortion always ends a human life even
if it's a deformed person or even if
it's very early stage human life and
that
the right to life is not merely one
right among many but it is it is the
fundamental right without which the
other rights cannot exist Kamala Harris
just had this this great quote the great
philosopher of our time Kamala she was
she was giving a speech at a
pro-abortion rally and she said you know
in our in our Declaration of
Independence we're promised we're
promised certain things we're promised
the right to
liberty and the pursuit of happiness I
kid you not yes you say wait what was
the that came before uh liberty no no I
think it was before the yada yada the
good part yeah the the right too uh
Liberty not what did you just call what
did I just hear and so you know you
can't pursue happiness without Liberty
and you can't have Liberty without you
don't pursue happiness without Liberty
you think so how can you pursue anything
without Liberty because there are people
who are in horrible places like I talk
about my book I've been to North Korea
who are pursuing happiness but oh when I
say Liberty I I mean it more in a in the
kind of Christian sense of the term
where you one can never take away the
liberty of one's mine oh yeah okay right
that is a priest precondition to
assuming happiness yes and so if if
slavery is a question of Liberty an
abortion is a question of life and
doesn't the question of life always have
to take precedence over the question of
Liberty yeah but I do think there are
certain cases we're taking first of all
I don't agree necessarily that early
abortion is a human life uh second of
all and that's a whole I know everyone
yes yes ignore the comments thank you
I'm sure there's something never heard
before
um but I I the fact that it's sometimes
to me acceptable whereas slavery is so
beyond the pale and I also love the idea
I can just hear the comments right now
that people even though that was the
question are going to tell me that me
being against slavery's virtue signaling
because you know that
I'm against it because he brought it up
I didn't bring it up spontaneously I
brought it up in response to the
question I like I like the idea that
it's not people aren't going to be upset
with you for being in support of
abortion in some cases right isn't it
it's that you're against slavery oh look
at this that's the internet for you I've
got to get heat for that yeah well okay
all right well I guess listen I guess I
got that wrong I mean I think I got the
question right but I I got your
intuition wrong maybe we slide down the
slippery slope six to 12 more months
maybe my answer will be correct by them
I am just gratified that these different
states that are enacting pro-life laws
are basically declaring themselves
anathema to awfuls affluent white female
liberals because it's like this isn't
your culture stay where you belong and
that to me is the most important aspect
of pro-life movement that's true hey you
know not most important but a very
important one but it is it's funny you
mentioned that because the pro-life
movement I mean there were Democrats in
the pro-life movement they're they're
leftists in the pro-life and which I
sometimes even forget because I think
it's all Conservative Christian
Republican type people but there is
something I think compelling as we see a
political realignment going on to just
people looking at and they say well
the people on the pro-abortion side
they're just terrible they're just wrong
about everything I found myself
pro-choice really because first of all
if we're in its day and age where
pro-choice means nine months I'm out of
here yeah of course this is not an
argument like what are you talking about
you know Dave Rubin last I talked to him
on this issue he was pro-choice he was
totally fine with abortion and I've
noticed over the years
he he I say well so when do you think
it's acceptable and he keeps pushing
that date back you know and I I think
it's he's following that I think he's
following the logic of abortion as he
thinks about these things but I think a
lot of it also has to do with wait a
second so these people who are
ostensibly on my side of this question
they're wrong about everything else you
know that was that was actually
ugly and and
physionomy is never wrong but the other
thing is it's also different once you
have a kid that's so when there's a face
and it's like oh then it's complete you
know but Uncle now it's not the same as
being a dad obviously but it's just like
okay there's a similarity yeah there's
things there's like okay okay I had I
mean I I know
plenty of women who have had abortions
and some early some very late and I I
did have this thought because I you know
I have two
two kids one just turned two the other
one is six seven months old and I was
holding my little infant baby and I was
thinking especially a couple months ago
I'm thinking
he doesn't look that different than he
did in the in the belly like that they
could it's like
this isn't you know they tell you the
pro-abortion people they tell you oh
it's you can't see the baby on a
microscope and it's all just a complete
lie I mean you can see these are like
real they got their little fingers by
like nine weeks or something very that's
true when you see seeing is believing I
guess